this according to britain's metropolitan
police force is denis sergeyev alias
sergey fedotov he's charged with being
the third man involved in the attempted
murder of sergey skripal and his
daughter yulia in the uk using the nerve
agent novichok in march 2018
a police officer nick bailey also became
critically ill and a woman dawn sturgis
died months later after she came into
contact with nerve agent left behind
skripal had been a russian spy turned
double agent feeding secrets to
britain's intelligence services released
as part of a spy swap he settled in the
wheelchair city of salisbury where he
was targeted say police by agents
working for russia's gru military
intelligence agency sergeyev is thought
to have been the man in charge prime
minister boris johnson demanded the
suspects be handed over
they should recognize that our sense
that justice must be done is not abated
and
dawn sturgis an innocent member of the
british public died in that event and we
want to see
those suspects handed over
it is the first time that british police
and prosecuting authorities have linked
the crime and all three suspects to the
gru confirming the findings of
independent investigations the trio are
alleged to have worked together before
in bulgaria and the czech republic
though this was the first time they'd
been active in the uk
however it is not the first time that
russia stands accused of going after its
enemies on uk soil in london in 2006
outspoken kremlin critic alexander
litvinenko died in agony after being
poisoned using a rare radioactive
isotope called polonium-210
it was slipped into his tea in a smart
london hotel allegedly by two russian
agents a judgment by the european court
of human rights has found that the
russian state was to blame for what it
described as an assassination
there haven't even been any results of
the investigation so far so such
statements are at the very least
unfounded we're not willing to take this
ruling on board
the kremlin continues to deny
involvement in both the skripal and
litvinenko cases and another thing
that's unlikely to change is that with
no extradition treaty and no help from
the russian authorities all the suspects
are likely to remain safe and at large
in russia jonah hull al jazeera